say hello to my little friend this is
the newest addition to the canon
powershot line this is the powershot n
as you can see it's a really tiny camera
there's almost no buttons on it that's
because most of the action happens on
the screen in the back the screen flips
up it's a touchscreen so you can use it
to take self-portraits you can use a
tissue from the hip all different kinds
of positions whenever you see something
on the screen that you want to take a
picture of you just tap and the camera
focuses and then fires off a shot there
are a few buttons on the side the one at
the top you switch from single shot mode
to creative shot mode that actually
shoots six pictures it shoots one
original photo and then five photos
where the camera automatically applies
different kinds of filters and the cool
thing about it is you'll get different
tints you'll get a black and white
picture you get some unique crops the
camera kind of makes up its mind of what
filters it's going to apply and what
kind of cropping that's going to apply
based on what you're shooting so if
you're taking a picture of a person do
the portrait shot taking a picture of a
sunset or a landscape it'll apply
different filters depending on what your
subject is there's also a little button
that instantly pairs it with your
smartphone you press this button and you
open up your phone you fire up an appt
it's called camerawindow it's created by
a cannon it's available for Android and
iOS the camera will pair with your phone
and then any pictures that are stored on
the camera you could transfer to your
phone wirelessly using an ad-hoc Wi-Fi
connection and then from your phone you
can share the photo however you want on
the bottom you can see there's a small
slot for SD cards it takes micro SD
cards there's also little teeny tiny
battery that recharges over USB the
canon powershot end is going to be
available in april it's going to cost
about $300 and if you're already using
cannons camerawindow app which is
available in the Google Play Store and
in the Apple App Store now you're going
to want to upgrade because the new
version that's going to be coming out
around the same time as this camera will
add a whole bunch of functionality that
will work with the end